we spent it we spent all several videos
now getting familiar with the Lawrence
transformations what I want to do now
instead of thinking of what X Prime and
CT prime is in terms of X and CT I'm
going to think about what is the change
in X Prime and the change in CT prime
going to be in terms of change in X and
change in CT and we'll see it's just
going to involve some some fairly
straightforward algebraic manipulation
so let's think about a change in X prime
is going to be X prime final minus X
prime X prime initial well X prime final
let me just pick a suitable color for
that X prime final is going to be gamma
times X final minus beta times CT final
all I did is I use this formula up here
if I want to figure out my final x prime
well I'm just going to think of my final
X and my final CT so that's that and
from that I am going to subtract the
initial X prime well X prime initial is
just going to be I get another color
here X prime initial is just going to be
Lorentz factor gamma times X initial
minus beta times CT initial so now let's
see we can factor out the gamma so this
is going to be equal to and I'll do it
in my color for gamma if we factor out
the gamma we're going to get gamma times
we're going to have X final let me do
this in a so we have let me do that in
white actually we're going to have X
final and then if we distribute this
negative sign minus X initial and then
let's see if we distribute this negative
sign well I don't want to skip too many
steps here so that's that and then we're
going to have negative we're going to
have negative beta CT final negative
beta CT final and then we have plus we
distribute this negative plus beta C T
initial
plus beta C T initial and so what can we
do it here
well this that's just going to be change
in X so this piece right here is just
change in X so I can rewrite this as
being equal to gamma gamma times change
in X change in X and now let me subtract
let me just subtract let me take let me
take out factor out a negative beta so
I'll say minus beta times minus beta
times well then you're going to have CT
final see T final minus CT initial minus
CT initial and well what's C T final
minus CT initial actually I'm not going
to skip any
I think I'm skipping too many steps
already well that's just going to be
change in CT so we get this is going all
going to be equal to gamma our Lorentz
factor times change in X minus beta
minus beta minus beta times change in CT
times change in CT and since C isn't
changing you could also view to see
times change in T either way so there
you have it
so these notice it takes almost the
exact same form X prime is equal to
gamma times X minus beta CT and change
in X prime is going to be gamma times
change in X minus beta times change in
CT and I'm not going to do it in this
video but you can make the exact same
algebraic argument for your change in CT
prime as you'll see and I encourage you
to do this on your own change in CT
prime which you could also view as since
C isn't changing C times Delta T prime
these are equivalent is going to be
equal to is going to be equal to exactly
what you would imagine is going to be
it's going to be gamma times change in
CT change in CT minus beta minus beta
times change in X and encourage you
right after this video
actually do this one too just hey Delta
X prime is going to be X X prime final
minus X prime initial and then do what I
just did here just little bit of
algebraic manipulation and you can make
the same exact argument over here to get
to the result that I just wrote down you
say well our change in CT prime is going
to be CT prime final minus CT prime
initial and you can substitute with this
do a little bit of algebraic
manipulation and you'll get that right
over there and the whole reason I'm
doing this is well now we can think in
terms of change in the coordinates which
will allow us to think about what
velocities would be in the different
frames of reference which is going to be
pretty neat